Junior.
So video is is the only approach they can
do, right?
So what they wanna do is so they they
Um.
have some,
they already have some video that senior.
So what they want to do is they will
utilize that for the AI.
That chat bot and then they will.
They will have all the um.
Video store it in SharePoint and then
shoot to that AI engine.
So if you look at the architecture
diagram,
there are some component to sorry.
There's some components to like analyze
the video and then when those junior guys
when this face some issue,
they'll go to the chat bot and search for
that for particular topics.
So that those video, yeah,
so those video maybe maybe one hour
different from before, maybe one hour,
Oh, oh, OK, got it, got it.
but the.
The engine need to analyze what are the
question and what are the relevant
material in the video so you can point
them exactly to that section.
Say for example yeah this question you
need to go to this video and if you look
By the time.
at.
uh to 30 minutes and then that's what you
want.
Got it. Um, super simple.
How much time they are giving us for this?
Yep.
Um, how much time?
So they don't have a timeline yet.
As soon as possible, I guess. Yep.
OK.
Do we have any budget? Do do?
Do they have any budget in mind?
Like how much they would like to invest
budget?
I will,
I will know maybe today or tomorrow.
OK, super simple.
So basically what technically what what
Yeah.
what is done in the market, right.
So this is some somewhere it's called a
Mhm.
rag, rag model RAG, right.
OK. Sorry. Yep.
The so if you want I can tell you the
full form operate.
I even I forgot the form of it.
It's called retrieval argumented
Uh huh.
generation. OK, So what it does.
So basically it converts all the
documents, all your videos. OK videos.
I I would say not videos, videos.
You convert the videos into transcripts,
right?
Mhm.
Yep, Yep, Yep.
And then it will it will remember the
metadata of this all information.
So basically when when I say metadata it
means like where does this document and
where does this video sits in OK and all
this information what is being extracted
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
right would be saved in a vector based
database.
OK, OK.
OK,
now this database database would be
connected to LLM model. OK,
but this LLM model is not meant to answer
Good.
anything,
any information outside this information,
outside this knowledge base what we have
so that it would be it would be tuned
Mhm.
like that. So it won't be connected.
It wouldn't be connecting to Internet and
try to do something.
Funny, you know,
so we can we can tune like that,
Mhm.
say that saying that whatever questions
are you going to get,
Uh huh.
you need to find the questions answered
in this set of documents what we have,
not nothing beyond that.
And if you're able to find it,
Yeah.
then you need to answer what exactly has
been written as per the document and need
to refer where exactly you find.
This information from which what?
What is the source of it?
So super simple I I think so it's being
done like multiple times.
OK.
If you want I I can create a very quick
architecture.
I think so we already have architecture
right?
Yeah, yeah. So, so let's do, let's do it.
I I think this is simple. Yeah,
Yeah, and simple, yes.
straightforward, simple. Let's do it.
Not super complex at this at this moment
because I still want want us to talk with
Microsoft first to understand 100% of the
requirement.
Or some hidden requirement that they know
from the client.
You.
But like last time you you you have the
architecture so you can talk with them,
OK.
verify with them based on that and then
we amend and then we have we create a
proposal like last time easy.
Cost cost. I will tell you the price.
I will tell you today or tomorrow.
OK, so you had shared me two use cases,
Semi AI knowledge based knowledge
management solution and ultimate.
So what is these two use cases?
Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah. OK. OK.
So so the the the left hand side,
that table is the current state.
That means they have nothing. Yeah.
Uh.
So what they want to achieve is the the
the the box in the middle.
But, but you can see the ultimate one,
yeah, if we can oppose to them, hey,
OK.
actually you don't need to,
you don't need to overthink.
We can go straight to the ultimate
solution with a low cost,
very quick deployment time to market.
Why not? Yeah.
Yeah, OK. Got it. Makes sense.
Yep.
Yep,
but the initial the the the the the
OK, guys. OK, Mark.
initial thought is to achieve the middle
one,
the middle term 1st and then do the
ultimate.
Hmm, got it, got it.
So the ultimate is to create videos and
all from from the short videos and all.
Yeah, OK, cool. That's possible.
Yep, Yep, Yep. Beside, beside, beside,
besides, besides video.
But that that's also possible.
Not not something like that.
There are also some training document,
but I don't think this is an issue if you
And.
can handle video document inside, yeah.
Hmm.
Yeah. Yeah. Cool. OK, man. Thank you.
Yeah.
OK. All right, man. Thank you so much.
Yep. Cheers. Bye, bye.
Yes, bye bye.
The core context for CLP is the industry-wide challenge of knowledge transfer.
We need to move this from senior experts to the next generation.
Correct. Technically, we start with a RAG model, but we need to handle specific
jargon like K2 and industry-specific keywords.
Exactly. It's not just a chatbot. This is a pilot strategy for a
whole learning platform in the future.
If we extend to the learning platform, I want to use an AI Avatar.
A text-to-speech avatar that can lead classroom training using a real person's likeness.
That is a strong use case. We can use AI Foundry to manage the
governance and multiple agents for different departments like HR and Legal.
They currently use SharePoint for knowledge. We need a management console
to handle document references and implementation plans.
I will submit the ballpark figure by Thursday or Friday.
We will calculate based on 1st-year Azure consumption to make it attractive.
Good. Early February is the target. Let's pitch the 'Marketplace of Value'
story to show how other organizations manage their AI Governance.
I'll prepare the case studies. We will show them how the
AI Avatar and Chatbot live together inside a platform like Viva Learning.
Perfect. Let's make it a business-focused story—HR, Legal, and Tech
all benefiting from one unified AI engine. Cheers.